we'll just take a look at this exclusive
fox video showing a massive horde of
migrants trying to bum rush their way
into the country at a port of entry in
El Paso it led to an intense standoff
that lasted hours as they clashed with
authorities border agents and riot gear
the Mexican military forced to fend off
the large group The illegals were
apparently told some false information
on social media
that said that they could be led into
the United States if they showed up at
the bridge with their kids Joe Biden
could see this Insanity for himself he's
only 100 miles away in California
but all we're getting is more nonsense
from his press secretary try to decipher
this
what we are going to promise is that
we're going to do this we're going to
move forward with a with a uh with this
kind of system this immigration system
that has been gutted really truly gutted
by the last Administration we're going
to move forward and do it in a humane
way we're going to do it in a safe way
and we're going to do it in the way that
moves us forward and so what we have
been seeing what we've been dealing with
again is trying to fix the damage that
the last Administration do did so
they're moving forward Dana yeah that's
a lot there's a lot of words a lot of
words there um one thing about that
video uh is at that sign you know it
says Felice
that means have a good trip or have a
good time I have a good trip like
they're not going on a vacation we need
to fix that sign although Felice viaje
that could actually be the Biden
reelection campaign because they're
about to go into this re-election with
this record on immigration and they're
trying to blame the as Brian was
pointing out they're trying to blame
everything on the Trump Administration
people can see things with their own
eyes and going into an election with
this record is pretty impossible to
imagine for me first of all they ran on
ending deportations and offering free
health care to illegal migrants that's
what that's what they did and then they
attempted to freeze deportations they
tried to end title 42 they stopped
Mounted Police off a border patrol from
riding their horses along the way they
also started moving people around in the
middle of the night
and then they all tried to blame the
Trump Administration which doesn't make
any sense it doesn't hold up and I I
think also if you're the press secretary
you actually don't have to do cable news
on a Friday night
like you really truly don't if you don't
have anything to say you can take a pass
and say I'll catch you on Monday not
Brian kilmate he's on every show that's
right right never said no but if someone
said explain and defend Joe Biden's
immigration system sorry I'm busy I'm
going clubbing but I would say this this
is what he's up against uh Senator
Menendez over the weekend came out and
said it's time for Joe Biden to stop
with this Crackdown he said these most
of these people from Cuba Venezuela
Nicaragua they're fleeing dictatorship
he's going to be known as the asylum
denier in Chief if he doesn't stop
denying these people Asylum so people on
his far left are as outraged as people
on the middle right about what he's
doing so it's not that he can't win he's
not trying the other thing to keep in
mind the New York Post said the cartels
put out that false tweet information to
force that flood at the border I'm
wondering that's related to the threats
that were leveled from Republicans over
the last few years so disinformation
from the cartel which I think is the
worst yeah that's the worst thing
nothing's worse than disinformation
Kennedy uh where is Nina jankowitz
find him with Nino does this look like a
fair and Humane and orderly process yeah
it actually I that this was video of
spring break and I had assumed that
someone put out a tweet that Taylor
Swift was on the other side of the
bridge and the Spring Breakers were so
excited to go meet Taytay that they uh
they just this is completely inhumane
this is not a this is not a functional
system this is cruel and they are
allowing this to happen and you know
it's like I was at the El Chapo trial I
was sitting there in the courtroom I was
there the day that his Lieutenant said
yeah we had 250 million dollars in a
suitcase that we gave to the president
of Mexico anyone can be gotten to and
I'm not saying that Senator Menendez has
been gotten to but he certainly is
taking a much more hospitable approach
to cartels he doesn't want to designate
them as terrorist organization but this
is a form of terrorism you know whether
you like it or not because people on
both sides of of this issue lose people
who are taking their kids trying to flee
wherever they are and the people in this
country who are competing for health
care and jobs usually the president
ignores images like this uh but these
images wake the country up when you see
this it's it's rude the way they're
acting
they're expecting something that they're
not deserved of and when do you think
the president's going to address the
Border crisis the last time he said he
had an app for this well sooner rather
than later and I think I think they're
trying I think you look at what's
happened in the last few weeks at least
from a posture standpoint on crime the
president made clear that he was not in
favor of what DC tried to do and
eventually got pulled back but he put
his foot down as well too he's decided
to do some drilling up in Alaska on this
energy piece which I think is an
incredibly important National Security
and National Economic Policy pivot that
he needed to do this this moment here is
is one crying out for some sort of
massive posture pivot as well politics
and elections bring about sometimes a
different person a different approach we
can all be proud of people who come to
our political side I know that my friend
friend who's come on who's now here at
the network Tulsi gabbard is now no
longer Democrat and people applaud that
there's some people that really applaud
it I like her a lot I don't agree with
her with everything but I think it's
she's become the person she wants to be
politically if President Biden believes
that we ought to have a different
posture at the border he should do it he
believes we should have a different
partial crime he believes would have we
should have a different posture and
energy it's going to take building a
wall it's going to take reforming the
Asylum process it's going to take
sending more D agents there and it may
even take a more creative military
strategy as we think about how the
cartels are treating American people
when they cross the border will we do
any of that well I don't think anybody
thought we'd drilled in Alaska a week
ago two weeks ago either the president
would approve that so I think
I said it Friday Dana predicted it she's
got a good night predictions are you
predicting anything on that border
they'll do something they have to
I'm with Dana something's better than
nothing I wanna Brian Kilmeade I want
you to do me a favor I want you to click
to subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
page this is the only way that I know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now